rayman assassin's creed ou encore les
lapins crétins
ils ont tous un point commun ubisoft une
entreprise française qui est spécialisé
dans le jeu vidéo depuis 1986 mais
saviez-vous que derrière c'est cette
lettre se cacher cinq bretons les frères
guillemot
les décisions finales sont prises il
faut qu'on soit en général on fonctionne
un peu dans un principe d'unanimité
c'est dire qu'on considère qu'on doit se
mettre d'accord
très vite ubisoft devient un acteur
majeur du secteur de jeu vidéo dix ans
seulement après sa création la société
fait son entrée en bourse avec succès
une consécration pour les cinq frères
ubisoft est un véritable touche à tout
et c'est lance même dans les jeux
éducatifs pour enfants
ça permet à l'enfant de s'impliquer est
bon de s'intéresser un petit peu plus et
de comprendre un peu mieux les l'utilité
en fait d'eux des matières qu'il apprend
à l'école
l'ambition des frères breton ne s'arrête
pas là et dépasse les frontières publie
stop ouvre plusieurs studios de
développement à travers le monde comme
shanghai en 1996 1997
montréal avec le plus gros studio de
développement au monde
petite visite guidée du studio en 2008
nous sommes au québec
mais ce studio est celui d'une
entreprise française ubisoft une petite
pme créée il ya une vingtaine d'années
par cinq frères et qui est aujourd'hui
le numéro trois mondial de cette
industrie des loisirs électroniques
après le jeu vidéo l'entreprise se lance
dans le cinéma avec l'adaptation de leur
saga phares assassin's creed en 2016 la
licence vendue à plus de 140 millions
d'exemplaires et la poule aux oeufs d'or
d'ubisoft en fait aujourd'hui les
vidéo on vraiment changer maintenant ce
nous créons des mondes très riche avec
beaucoup de personnages beaucoup de
décors bonne façon d monde en fait
et donc ces matériaux très intéressant
pour raconter des tas d'histoires
aujourd'hui les cinq frères guillemot
sont toujours à la tête de la société
avec 2 milliards d'euros de chiffre
d'affaires et seize mille salariés en
2019 ubisoft est devenu le troisième
éditeur indépendant mondial du jeu vidéo
[Musique]